on va parler donc un peu de vous Salomé
saké et surtout de votre livre paresseux
inculte individualiste c'est pour battre
en brèche tous les clichés sur la
jeunesse que vous avez pris la plume
soit jeune et tais-toi chez Payot c'est
le titre c'est aussi un slogan de 68 on
voit cela dans l'invitation de Maïté
Frémont et on en parle ensemble juste
après regarde
si on vous invite Salomé saké c'est pour
nous parler de la Genèse 9 millions de
Françaises et de Français
âgés de 18 à 29 ans une génération à qui
l'on dit selon vous trop souvent soit
jeune et tais-toi titre clin d'oeil d'un
slogan de Mai 68 pour nourrir cette
enquête de 277 pages vous avez recueilli
de nombreux témoignages de jeunes façon
pour vous de répondre à ceux qui disent
deux qu'ils sont narcissiques ou encore
paresseux clichés qui colle à la peau du
jeûne qui a souvent du mal à se faire
entendre pas seulement celui
d'aujourd'hui mais aussi celui d'hier
j'aurai le temps une minute de m'énerver
juste de m'énerver et de paraître pour
un petit merdeux et un petit jeune de
plus difficile à pagaille partout je
préfère m'en aller tout de suite si
j'avais su que je n'aurais rien dire
j'aurais dormi beaucoup plus tard je
vous remercie votre présence
je ne soulève toi Salomé saké vous avez
27 ans vous êtes suivi sur Twitter par
plus de 174 000 personnes vous êtes
journaliste engagé dites-vous mais
surtout pas militante nouveau visage
médiatiques le grand public vous
découvre notamment chez nous sur LCP
vous l'aurez compris protéger les océans
c'est une question de survie vous
assumez une posture générationnelle sur
des sujets comme la crise climatique ou
encore économique soit jeune et tais-toi
et votre tout premier ouvrage et vous
l'expliquez dès le début une séquence
déclenche l'écriture de ce livre
là je suis pas libre à cause de vous on
va pas vivre
[Musique]
le 25 mai dernier un homme d'une
soixantaine d'années actionnaire de
Total énergie insulte cette jeune
militante pour le climat qui bloque
l'entrée du groupe boomer versus jeune
indignation que vous mais en carburant
mais les jeunes écologistes se sont ceux
qui s'engagent pour leurs vieux
écologistes vous savez moi j'ai connu
des écologistes bien pluvieux que moi
qui qui était extrêmement militant
extrêmement engagé certains ont éclairé
les générations présentement parce qu'il
y a eu beaucoup de choses qui ont été
faites depuis les années 60-7080 tout le
monde l'oublie y compris en matière de
tri etc et donc je pense que la réalité
est beaucoup moins manichéenne que ce
que vous affirmez là alors une question
ce soir Salomé saké comme le disait
Pierre Bourdieu la jeunesse n'est-elle
pas qu'un mot et l'âge une donnée
socialement manipulable et il manipuler
réponse Salomé saké oui bien sûr que la
jeunesse n'est qu'un mot après elle est
quand même encadrée statistiquement
parce que c'est quand même des enjeux
différents auxquels font face les
différentes tranches d'âge donc
effectivement il faut mettre des
chiffres à un certain moment et faire
des choix moi dans mon livre j'ai choisi
de parler des 18 29 ans mais bien sûr
que c'est ouvert à toutes les
interprétations un peu lui faire un peu
dire ce qu'on veut elle pense aussi elle
pense cela il faut prendre ça à faire je
parle vraiment pas d'une jeunesse mais
de déjeunesse elle est sociologues sont
toujours très attention à dire des
jeunesse pas une jeunesse et
effectivement à ne pas essayer de faire
dire à une un corps indéfini tout et
n'importe quoi quel cliché qui vous
agace le plus sur la jeunesse je me dis
beaucoup paresseuse génération Y qui
passaient 18 heures quitter le bureau
c'est vraiment les accusations en
paraissent qui reviennent beaucoup que
moi j'ai beaucoup pu entendre aussi dans
mon entourage et qui ne se retrouve pas
du tout dans les chiffres en réalité
aujourd'hui les jeunes veulent
réellement travailler veulent construire
aussi un avenir meilleur veulent
participer à notre
[Musique]
et plus grande chez les jeunes est-ce
que c'est la faute des boomers alors
c'est je pense que c'est complètement
inutile de chercher des coupables et je
le précise à de nombreuses reprises je
cherche pas à blâmer une classe d'âge au
même titre que j'aime pas qu'on
propose des clichés sur les jeunes je
voudrais pas moi divulguer des clichés
sur les plus âgés et je pense vraiment
que ça sert à rien c'est plus une idée
de comment est-ce qu'on construit la
suite de manière indéniable les ce qu'on
appelle les boomers enfin les baby
boomers génération d'après guerre avec
les trois épées progrès prospérité
pleine emploi et paix les quatre P les
quatre pe de l’historien Jean-François
cyrinelli effectivement ont été utilisés
pour qualifier une espèce de parenthèse
dorée on peut pas culpabiliser les gens
qui ont vécu ça d'en avoir profité ce
qu'on essaie de dire c'est que ceux qui
nous critiquent eux n'ont pas eu souvent
à gérer les mêmes choses vous êtes
d'accord pour dire que les aînés ont
bien conscience des difficultés
je pense que évidemment il doit toujours
y en avoir mais moi j'entends beaucoup
dans mon entourage surtout dans la
bouche des jeunes que j'ai interrogé et
qui était si nombreux à me dire mais
merci d'écrire ce livre parce que je
vais pouvoir l'offrir à mes parents
l'offrir à mes grands-parents pour
qu'enfin ils comprennent pour préciser
on fait face vous avez interrogé des
jeunes à partir de votre communauté de
followers c'est ça l'idée au tout début
mais après pas du tout je suis vraiment
passée par je suis allé directement sur
le terrain dans des endroits où j'ai pu
trouver des jeunes notamment dans des
établissements scolaires où je suis allé
interroger des jeunes pour le
complètement au hasard où j'ai essayé de
passer par d'autres sources donc j'ai
vraiment fait l'effort d'interroger des
jeunes qui ne connaissaient pas mon
travail qui n'avait pas du tout les
mêmes idées politiques que moi il y a
vraiment des jeunes d'une gauche plutôt
radicale jusqu'à l'extrême droite en
passant par des jeunes complètement
apolitiques et au début vous leur
demandiez enfin c'était l'idée quels
sont vos rêves absolument vous avez
annoncé à cette question c'est ça oui
parce qu'en fait j'ai posé des questions
extrêmement basiques aux jeunes c'était
vraiment racontez-moi votre vie et
d'ailleurs ils étaient très nombreux
voire tous ont accepté en fait de me
raconter ce qu'il est préoccupé et donc
dans les questions il y avait à quoi
vous rêvez et très rapidement j'ai
changé de question c'était plutôt est-ce
que vous rêvez parce que j'ai constaté
un certain pessimisme
très profond chez les jeunes que j'ai
retrouvé après dans les toutes les
études de statistiques sociologiques qui
sont menées où on a une augmentation du
pessimisme ou les jeunes ont des
difficultés profondes à se projeter dans
l'avenir et à s'imaginer vivre dans 10
20 30 ans dans ce monde qui est de plus
en plus sombre de plus en plus
inquiétant et qui ne leur promet rien de
vraiment
bon pour l'avenir on va parler du
dérèglement climatique dans un instant
c'est l'une des principales angoisses
vis-à-vis de la vie Emmanuel Macron
l'avait reconnu cette phrase c'est dur
d'avoir 20 ans en 2020 il la prononçait
pendant la pandémie vous trouvez qu'il a
rien compris qu'il a rien fait pour les
jeunes alors clairement il n'a pas fait
le nécessaire et ça c'est pas moi qui le
dis ce sont les différents économistes
et sociologues qui aujourd'hui sont
observateurs de ce qui se fait en termes
de politique publique pas un euro dans
les CROUS préservatifs je parle pas en
mon module du lendemain politique
économique je parle pas à mon ange donne
vraiment je suis allée interviewer des
économistes des sociologues qui trouvent
que c'est totalement insuffisant et donc
oui il y a eu un effort qui a été fait
d'ailleurs qui a un certain coût je
pense au plan un jeune une je pense
aujourd'hui au service national
universel qui coûte plutôt cher en
termes de politiques publiques mais
le service national universel pour moi
est vraiment un exemple de politique
inadapté de la jeunesse c'est à dire que
ça coûte deux mois qui sont en train de
renoncer à la généralisation ça coûte 2
milliards d'euros et à côté de ça on a
la moitié des fils alimentaires pour
l'aide des Restos du cœur qui sont
composés de moins de 26 ans c'est à dire
qu'il y a des jeunes qui n'ont pas à
manger aujourd'hui il y a des gens qui
n'arrivent pas à se loger si vous allez
demander aux jeunes c'est quoi votre
problème aujourd'hui la plupart c'est la
précarité l'accès à l'emploi l'accès aux
études et on leur propose une mesure
enfin qui vaut extrêmement cher service
national complètement décalé tu ne
correspond pas à la réalité donc il y a
eu des petites petites mesures comme le
repas 1 euro qui sont arrivés souvent
très tard en pleine pandémie et on a mis
huit mois à avoir vraiment des mesures
qui soient mises en place par le
gouvernement et qui sont totalement
insuffisantes dernière chose qu'il
faudrait faire tiens parce que le
constat il est implacable mais il y a
beaucoup d'idées dans le débat un RSA
jeune par exemple un revenu universel ça
vous seriez favorable vous parler
beaucoup aussi de la jeunesse des
politisée est-ce qu'il faudrait faire le
vote obligatoire c'est des pistes ou pas
pour vous moi la première des pistes
c'est d'écouter la jeunesse et c'est
vraiment pour ça que j'ai écrit ce livre
et c'est pour ça qu'il est vraiment à
destination aussi quoi des plus âgés
pour aider responsable politique bien
évidemment de se dire mais en fait les
préoccupations première des jeunes c'est
ça et clairement les politiques
publiques aujourd'hui ne répondent pas à
ses préoccupations là moi je suis pas
économiste je ne suis pas une femme
politique je veux pas dire la solution
ce serait trop simple en revanche
j'essaie de donner la parole à des
spécialistes qui eux proposent des
solutions donc effectivement il y a le
RSA pour les moins de 25 ans il y a des
politiques de l'emploi il y a des
réinjections notamment d'argent dans le
système d'éducation nationale il y a
plein de propositions qui aujourd'hui en
tout cas ne sont pas écoutées mais vous
êtes quand même optimiste sur les
générations la guerre des générations
n'aura pas lieu c'est une fausse guerre
écrivez vous d'ailleurs vous reprenez la
phrase de Camille Étienne dans son
documentaire pourquoi et en fait on ne
peut pas se permettre d'avoir une guerre
de générations aujourd'hui c'est
indispensable que les plus âgés nous
nous écoutent et une forme d'empathie
une empathie assez forte à l'égard des
jeunes générations pour vouloir
préserver leur futur et je parle
d'urgence écologique et je donne encore
une fois la parole à des scientifiques
des personnes qui nous expliquent à quoi
va ressembler le monde dans lequel on
est en train de nous léguer aujourd'hui
et clairement ça nous rend ça nous
terrifie pour une grande partie des
jeunes et on l'a vu dans le reportage
d'ailleurs que vous avez fait tout à
l'heure donc on a besoin que les plus
âgés non seulement nous considèrent et
ne nous blâme pas quand on essaie de
s'engager mais en plus nous aide à leur
échelle et vite parce qu'on ne peut pas
attendre et on a besoin d'une
mobilisation intergénération immédiate
pour terminer est-ce que vous pensez que
les démocraties sont les systèmes
politiques les plus adaptés aux mesures
radicales qu'il faut prendre pour le
contre le réchauffement climatique
Jean-Marc Jancovici par exemple qu'une
dictature éclairée pour planifier à 50
ans serait plus utile moi je pense qu'on
peut pas arriver à faire accepter des
choses massivement sans démocratie et
sans participation citoyenne et c'est
pour ça encore une fois que j'écris ce
genre de d'ouvrage c'est que j'espère
que ça va passer demain en main et qu'on
va réussir à construire collectivement
et pas une personne en haut qui
imposerait ça en tout cas et elles sont
il est passé par les mains de la
rédaction de la chaîne parlementaire
soit je n'étais toi séché Payot réponse
à ceux qui critiquent la jeunesse
premier bouquin et c'est une somme
extrêmement documentée signée Salomé